[Musique]
les fans ses ventes était incroyable
ouais je déconne pas tu crois qu'il
serait arrivé s'il n'avait pas été là
céderait pas sur la loire ce que tu leur
as à un sur cent le même truc et huawei
j'ai foiré fois
autour des bosses à bord
[Musique]
j'étais déjà parlé de mon frère je sais
pas ce qui s'est passé exactement mais
il a été arrêté
ils l'ont enfermé à riga
[Musique]
oh merde théorie bbh210 de l'avant que
ça se termine mal que quelqu'un lui
lyon
je
émile de plus saisonnier vous me
rapportez encore dix mille pote frère
est libre
quelque chose me dit que je vis un truc
super important comme si mon destin
était en train de se jouer ce week-end
zinjibar est une entité
[Musique]
le pétrole
nos quelle cruche par un connecteur
monsieur nov
[Musique]